[Wet With Regret from Closer To Me Than Him plays]
[muffled music]
[ding-dong]
[getting up noises]
[muffled getting up noises]
[crash]
Heeeiii gaiz!
How you doing?
Welcome to LA!
[squeaky nipples]
Come on in!
My home is your home. Get ready for...
...a week of amazing video gaming.
[pure amazement]
You don't even know it's gonna happen!
[neck snaps]
OH, it's good to see you!
You know, I've always respected you as a person.
[epic slow mo is epic]
DAAAENIEALH, good to see ya!
OH, you've always been a good little boy.
Put it there!
[epic slow mo is still epic]
[...and triumphant, too!]
[Wade pops up]
What the fuck are you doing here Wade?!
[epic slow mo is not so epic now, is it? :D]
[btw the song is Glub Glub Water Dance,
goddammit stop asking :D]
[ding-dong]
[epic slow mo is definitely epic again]
[normal speed touching commences]
[laughing]
It's whe...
It's when you squeeze my face that makes me laugh.